un desagravio histórico a las víctimas
de la masacre de napalpí en argentina un
juicio que no busca responsables penales
sino la verdad de lo ocurrido en una
matanza de indígenas perpetrada en el
año 1924 tenemos esta gran
responsabilidad no sólo para conocer la
verdad sino también para poder como dije
antes reactivar la memoria y generar
memoria colectiva para que hechos de
esta naturaleza y las grandes
violaciones a derechos humanos por parte
de los excesos del poder del estado ya
no vuelvan a repetirse porque no estamos
exentos de que aun viviendo en
democracia esto pueda suceder la masacre
fue perpetrada por un centenar de
policías gendarmes y colonos quienes
fusilaron cerca de 300 miembros de los
pueblos indígenas con mimo con que
protestaban para exigir mejores
condiciones de vida y laborales el
proceso judicial cuenta con pruebas
surgidas de una investigación especial
de la secretaría de derechos humanos
argentina según la fiscalía existió una
estrategia de estado para negar y
encubrir la matanza que abordaremos el
caso denominado más al vivir a los fines
de demostrar con la mayor rigurosidad
posible cómo se sucedieron los hechos en
qué contexto se llevaron a cabo quiénes
fueron las víctimas y quiénes fueron sus
responsables este es un juicio que
construirá mediante la justicia a decir
del secretario de derechos humanos de la
nación suramericana una verdad que quede
escrita y que repare simbólicamente a
los familiares de las víctimas a la
democracia y a las nuevas generaciones